hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to the resident evil 2 demo
now I don't know if the time has started
has the clock started I have no idea but
I only have 30 minutes to play this game
no matter what happens no matter what I
do if I don't get to the end of the demo
in 30 minutes on dunzo so I'm gonna go
into this with all the hope in the world
that I'm not gonna suck ass which is
usually what I do in these circumstances
so I'm assuming that the second I open
up this game it's on let's find out
that's some big Wubba JH let's do this
I'm ready okay the final game may differ
from this demo the demo is only playable
for one-off 30-minute trial this demo
can only be played online well I'm all
those things so good great I feel good
about this alright come on bring it on
what have you got for me it was supposed
to be a short break for Leon s Kennedy
just one last pit stop at a gas station
on the outskirts of town when the rookie
cop found himself surrounded in a sea of
zombies along with a newfound friend
Claire Redfield Leon managed to escape
to Raccoon City only for an accident to
split them apart definitely navigating
through the perilous streets Leon has
made his way to the city's police
station but has he really made it to
safety
oh it's so like Resident Evil 4 hi
anybody I should probably hurry up but
am I gonna all right combined
alright nokey dokey then so there's no
point in saving oh I have time to watch
a movie why not hey are you doing
someone here oh what a babyface
[Applause]
that seems like somebody okay well that
was easy
okay I gotta find that guy man you're
handsome I'm smart not been through some
[ __ ] before so I know exactly what I got
get it going on ooh well I don't have
time to look at the menu I don't have
time for anything I gotta go I think
anyway I got a sprint headfirst into
danger well hello
a boozled ok so that's good to know what
about over here is this suppose --all is
everything weirdly locked in here
probably a bunch of puzzles you know
like any government building should be
if this is the police department
oh yeah oh of course of course this
police department would have many
different puzzles and mysteries and keys
and secrets of all which we're keeping
in here well I came up here for nothing
I probably should have consulted my map
ok I'm not stupid I'm a little bit
stupid but I'm not stupid
hey that tape looks familiar hey whoa
God I can't be lost I can't be lost I
only got 30 minutes well I got 30
minutes okay there's something there
yeah the taped up box is a thing
[Music]
what abort is that over there oh what's
that is that useful is that good for me
keep out well you know how I am
oh yeah yeah oh baby hello can i crawl
under there oh hell yeah I can Oh stick
my head first get it right in there any
zombies oh the bloods a good sign hmm
yeah that's no bueno all right looks
clear let's just go first for it and I
will be playing this game in full when
it comes out which comes out next week
which is going to be awesome
I cannot wait I loved Resident Evil 7 so
much I came away just hey I'm vamping
here talking about how much I like the
game alright fine then I'll see you in a
second don't worry there cold brewski to
tide me over oh oh thanks thanks I think
he's talking to me
I do got this story I won't guide you
into the grips of death okay ah there we
go thank you for being helpful I did
most of the work there though alright
hello anybody here who know nothing here
how's that sound hello
oh it's don't look good oh ah
all this don't look good at all oh okay
nothing hello who's in here
peekaboo NYPD peekaboo
what's that Oh dandy all right cool ha
Oh someone didn't wipe properly hello
okay hey uh-huh it looks good oh [ __ ] I
want to I really want to
oh that thing really got him oh yeah oh
the officers notebook I gotta get the
three medallions through later weird
area here that I know about parking it
way out oh oh oh it's clues its Blue's
Clues okay all right so something about
the bird the lady in the unicorn the
crown the line and the goat I'm not
gonna remember any of that but thank you
for your noble sacrifice I'm drawing it
I'm firing listen buddy
get down that was not nice hey you all
suck yeah they are okay got him I think
hope that's enough to kill him because
if it's not I'm in trouble oh please let
me through
Oh No I love you eat it like that guy
did help please I shot you
my friend
oh you too for now Leon Kennedy there
was another officer I could yeah take my
bloody hand I'm sure you did what you
could Leon I'm so excited for this game
I don't care if I get to via
don't get to the end of a demo because
I'm gonna play the full game when it
comes out but honestly all you need to
know is that this place will eat you
alive if you argue yeah I'm supposed to
start last week and I got a call to stay
away I wish I'd come here sooner yeah
now that's all that matters
[Applause]
okay lieutenant I'm ready hopefully
we'll be able to find a way out of this
station that officer you made earlier
Eliot he thought this secret passageway
might do the trick
hmm this is good news we can get you to
a hospital no no I am NOT the priority
here lieutenant I'm not just gonna leave
you here I'm giving you an order
rookie you save yourself first I'd come
with you but I just slow you down
yeah you would you would this your gun
oh stop don't make my mistake if you see
one of those things uniform or not you
do not hesitate you take it out
or you run got it yes sir
I'm glad that he grabbed onto that
notebook so it could be covered in blood
also this combat knife do all right
space to ready something to sub weapon
oh yeah oh yeah oh yeah I know what to
do with this
alright so I made the mistake of going
up and around and wasting some time but
I think if I go over here I know that
this is the dealio yeah okay yeah a
sweet knife that was all that was
holding it I coulda shot that that would
open right up yeah yeah it's like the
opposite of I'm too old for this [ __ ]
I can't can I no there we go that's a
little tricky to get used to but I shall
get used to it because I don't have time
to do anything otherwise what did I come
here for oh here we go
hello Picabo anybody here oh hey I was
told not to hesitate but I'm still alive
no hesitation hello
[Applause]
he's smiling oh no oh no ha ha class
that's not that's not healthy that's
that oh okay you know what I'm just
gonna move on oh I kind of like this
Shh I kind of like that
they oh god oh oh oh you okay I kind of
like that's a I kind of like that they
went third-person for this one like the
old style well the old cell wasn't even
third-person it was like a top-down
fixed camera perspective but this one is
um it's good hey hey
sorry no vampires I if I don't invite
you in you can't get in sorry all right
I'll I'll let you in do about this
you need some first aid the gun Matilda
is it the name of the gun
well that um well I can't just shoot you
know Hey well Jesus how amazing you how
many do you need
just oh those things you just flopped in
there to die alright whatever
no not that no not no James I need to
stop wasting ammo like that like what
like a dick stop wasting animal I could
dick oh hello oh wow that's Andy all
right well good for me I got some this
there alright so getting quicker but
it's not gonna be enough cuz I'm running
out of time record of events to save one
refugees times death an officer mob at a
vegetation another clash on the west
side okay's basically in summary zombies
attacked and wheeze did ooh
Andy okay uh-huh
I like this oh oh oh you're right there
buddy
this back in the vending machine is it
real hey oh you're hungry man but come
on have some dignity I'm gonna get you
I'll get you your big okay you're bigger
than I thought you'd be oh my I need
that
oh I need that I need that I need that I
need that please give me that I need
that okay you did okay I think he's dead
mm-hmm all right what was he bashing
over there you could have just reached
frightened you idiot I didn't have to
kill you for nothing
well I got a go fly running out of time
oh hey buddy how ya writin the point
right in the boy right in the boy no
legs no legs no legs no legs
you got no legs all right that's what I
thought all right you too yeah norm no
arm no legs no legs huh you're no legs
no brains stupid world no mind if I do
uses of gun power it blows [ __ ] up ooh
okay got it got it thank you
anybody else want a tussle tussle with
the muscle yeah yeah yeah
thorns nor arms norm oh oh oh [ __ ]
didn't know that could happen didn't
know that could huh well alright well
sure dealt with him um one nope okay
you're dead what happened to my knife
didn't know the knife could break like
that I thought it was a good knife oh
well I guess the lesson learned is that
I should probably run a bit more than I
have been that's the other side of the
other that's the other side of the other
area there where am I West office oh
there's something over here
apparently I think something uh-oh there
was something in there did I miss it
how did I miss it oh it's the safe okay
it's just the safe - 115 that there's no
way to learn that okay [ __ ] really
don't you [ __ ] you you know what eat eat
- eat a chode I need to go this way okay
goodbye
stupid startling bastard what's in here
this is important what is this whoa
weapon Locker I can't type anything 104
okay is there what about on this okay
what about on this is is say what number
it is weapon Locker key card
cuz that seems like it should be this
stuff okay I don't know how that works I
don't have time for this but this that
is what I was looking for huzzah
oh come to Papa
yes oh it only takes up one slot yes yes
get ready for a face full of kaboom
what's a face full of kaboom
you're anybody ready for a face full of
kaboom I am out of here
a face full of an earth-shattering
kaboom Oh Andy all right wooden boards
Andy
facing like a boom would anybody like a
hefty deliver egde of kaboom no not
today okay whatever you say
dark room you say hello I've got nothing
for this ooh red herb okay ooh film
contains evidence do not leave out mmm I
probably screwed it up already you can't
save some kind of a book there medical
bill I know
herbs I know herbs already no herbs give
me that [ __ ] from that [ __ ] perfect no
no no combine with that there we go
still gonna use that it's a little
tricky put this in there put this in
there all right we're good to go let's
go come on we gotta go go go you'll get
so much time you ready for a cup over
I'll kaboom you yeah you good kabooms
another day oh no that's not good
probably hello anybody here men's locker
room Oh Steve it's impossible I can't
possibly traverse it well
poopie okay replacement kaboom errs
how's it go fit in there anyway a bunch
of BS if you ask me
hello I don't remember you being there
hey whoa
sorry all right man
it had to be done and to be done who
else is here give me put yeah all right
let's do this
somebody hiding in this locker - come on
STFU no I don't know what all the
puzzles are oh you sexy lady
Oh key oh that's handy alright I got
that I know what that goes to just don't
know where to put it
don't let it I didn't see what it was
was it scary looking
did it look scary another plank perfect
I like wooden planks
Oh what is the moulding alright fine
goodbye
see you buddy are you Oh statue okay
some guys scribblings and those
corporate [ __ ] boarded all these
filthy pigs up in a steel pin and set
some c4 oh oh it's just some guys stupid
ramblings about nothing
oh no it wasn't stupid ramblings about
nothing it was it was legit it was legit
what happened in this place this is a
police department at least that's what I
thought it was right this is a police
department right hello right there
well yeah it's just one all right I
don't know why this guy is just casually
eating hey don't mind me no no don't no
no no listen listen listen listen listen
you don't need to do nothing
oh really really that didn't do a full
blast all right what do I do with this
oh to move the things around good god
there's so many detailing so many I
don't trust ya really fine oh I'm
getting back
I'm coming Marvin Marvin I'm here Marvin
Marvin I'm on the way
go away you wreck him I'm almost there
Marvin Marvin hello yeah I knew she'd
make it yeah I did do ya ya name's
Claire I came into town with her you can
get to that courtyard through the second
floor East Side I'm on it
thanks lieutenant
that's all you came to tell me oh oh but
I did it oh well I am pretty good Wow oh
well I guess that's it god damn it
dagnabbit dammit dagnabbit dagnabbit
alright but don't worry I'm going to
play this game in full when it comes out
on like the 25th we were going to do a
full playthrough this because I am so
down for this there needs to be more
triple-a horror games and this one
spooked me pretty good too I like that a
lot so thank you everybody so much for
watching let me know what you think down
in the comments below and look forward
to my playthrough this game when it
comes out on the 20-somethings v maybe
so thanks again and as always I'll see
you in the next video
[Music]